This video is sponsored by NordVPN.
This right here, is one of my all time favourite
moments in One Piece. The energy. The emotions
and the impact it carries are simply fantastic.
However I think it takes a quite unique place
in this series. Because, while most of the other
iconic moments in One Piece are based on positive,
empowering or sentimental scenes, when Luffy walks
up to Charlos to punch him in the face the strong
emotion this moment carries is one of burning rage
and anger. This shot works so incredibly well,
because it scratches the sting itch that
chapter 502 and episode 396 of One Piece
have built up to that point. And the feeling of
helplessness, injustice and despair that not only
the characters, but also the audience experiences
is something that is quite unique in Oda’s story.
It is in this chapter I believe, that Oda fully
pulls aside the colourful shounen curtain with
which he covers his story and exposes the
true, dark dystopia of his story world,
that we otherwise only get small glimpses at.
And so in today’s video, I want to discuss
with you why I believe that 502 is the darkest
chapter of the entire story so far with an almost
shakespearean level of tragedy and why it makes
Luffy’s punch one of the best scenes in the story.
Oh yeah, and if you haven’t already, make sure
to subscribe to the channel. We’re actually
getting really damn close to hitting 100K.
The scene takes place in the first half of the
Sabaody Archipelago Arc that until today is
one of my favourite Arcs overall. The Mermaid
Camie has been kidnapped by human traffickers
to be sold at a salve auction, and the straw hats
have entered the auction hall planning to use the
200 million berry of treasure they have to buy
her free without causing any major commotion.
Next to the general high society of the One
Piece world, dressed in glamorous cloths,
three celestial dragons have joined the auction
as well, and so have Eustas Kid and Trafalgar Law.
Before their eyes a young dancing girl
is being sold for 7.2 Million Berry.
Meanwhile, a very frustratedCharlos, who wants to
buy a mermaid to be chased around in his piranha
tank,kicks another of his slaves. The next
candidate is a former renowned pirate captain,
that is now being sold off like cattle. Before
anyone in the audience can start bidding however,
his mouth starts filling with blood and he
collapses on the floor. As it turns out he has
bitten off his tongue to kill himself rather
than become a slave. Next up is finally Camie,
who like all other slaves wears a collar that
will explode should anyone try to remove it.
The crew seems confident to get her, however upon
seeing the mermaid, Charles immediately bids 500 M
Berries and seals the deal for her to the shock
of everyone else in the room. The now terrified
Camie tries to scream out toHatchan, but her
cries can’t reach though the walls of her tank.
When Kid decides to leave upon seeing all this,
Luffy and Zoro finally reach the hall as well
in their typical fashion, by smashing through the
roof. Upon seeing Camie Luffy starts towards her
tank, but is stopped by Hacchan, who accidentally
reveals all of his arms and thus him being a
fishman. This immediately creates panic within
the auction hall as the fishmen are not only
strongly discriminated against here, but actually
banned from even setting foot on the island.
And so for the very first time the crew gets
to witness the true level of discrimination
against their race first hand. The turmoil
stops as suddenly as it has started when the
room is suddenly pirced by gun fire. As Luffy
turns around, he sees Hacchan falling over,
shot by none other than the Celestial Dragon
Charlos, who is excitedly celebrating his kill.
In this moment Luffy’s entire demeanour changes.
While the onlookers are relieved that the
dangerous and disease-riddled monster has been
killed, he starts walking towards the Tenryubito.
The heavily wounded Hacchan tries to stop
him, blaming himself for what happened
and apologising that he could not make up
for what he had done to Nami and her village,
fully redeeming his character. This however
just seems to harden Luffy’s resolve.
Unstoppable he closes in on Charlos, who fails
to shoot him, and Luffy punches him in the face
so hard, that he leaves a permanent
imprint of his fist on his face.
And speaking of imprints, I would like to talk
for a moment about the sponsor of today’s video,
NordVPN. While Luffy definitely
left an imprint on Charlos,
I don’t recommend doing so yourself
when it comes to your activity online.
If you followed the channel for a while you will
know that I rarely do sponsorships, since I only
want to work with companies I am comfortable
with and can recommend. I’ve been using NordVPN
myself the past 2 years mostly to unlock Japanese
Netflix to watch the first season of terrace house
and I’m also using it to watch anime that are not
available in Germany, like One Piece. Occasionally
a server might not work perfectly, but with
over 5000 fast servers in over 59 countries
and unlimited bandwidth, it’s super easy to just
choose a new one, hit refresh and you’re good to
go. As a member of the fox gang you can now get
68% off NordVPN for $3.71 a month plus an entire
additional month for free at nordvpn.com/ohara.
The link is in the description below.
Something I can’t put in the description
below, is describe how much I love that scene.
I mean. What a rollercoaster of a chapter. So much
negativity, cruelty and immorality building up in
just 16 pages. Emotional storytelling at its
best. I think you will probably already have
a good idea what makes this chapter so incredibly
dark, even though no-one dies, no-one is betrayed
and nothing is lost. I think Kid summaries it best
in this panel here, where he fittingly describes
the auction house as a miniature of the world.
What does he mean by that? Well you see, Sabaody
is the first arc that we actually meet the world
nobles and see their rule and tyranny in action.
In the world of One Piece they stand on top of
the food chain. They are a tiny group of people
that hold most of the wealth and power of the
world. Anything that they want, they get. Laws
don’t apply to them, they are made to make their
lives better. They have complete control over
the World Government and if a civilian so much
as crosses paths with one without bowing down,
they will be shot and killed. They literally see
themselves as the gods of the One Piece world,
and they certainly behave and live that way.
And so when Kid says that the slave auction
is like the world in miniature it tells us an
awful lot about the state of the world itself.
As will be confirmed later in the story,
it means that even on a large scale, the
Celestial Dragons simply do what they want with a
disregard for human life, morality and humanity.
They dominate everything and everyone and no-one
is able to lift so much as a finger against them.
Luffy’s friend Camie suddenly is nothing more
than a product that is sold to the highest bidder
to amuse his twisted fantasies. So the scene
gives us a first major glimpse at who the
World Government truly represents and what the
true cruelty of the One Piece world looks like.
And, just as Kid stated the Human auction House
is a wonderful narrative symbol for all of that.
Even though it is the centre of unjust and inhuman
slave trade, the Marines euphemistically refer to
it as the Public Employment Security Office. I
probably don’t have to tell you that referring
to slave work as employment has happened plenty
of times throughout real history as well in an
attempt to soften and normalise the exploitation
of humans. It’s not a mere sign of corruption
within the marines, but they literally have
no other choice but to look the other way,
as they directly obey the celestial dragons’ rule.
What makes the symbolism of the auction house even
more fitting however is the fact that it was
owned by none other than Donquixote Doflamingo,
the leader of the Underworld, powerful warlord
and one of the cruelest antagonists in the story.
It truly says nothing good about the world
if it resembles something run by Doflamingo,
who’s own country that can also be
seen as a miniature of the world,
was one of the darkest and corrupt
places the straw hats have visited.
Doflamingo being a former Celestial Dragon himself
is of course just the the cherry on top then,
as he himself has suffered his entire
life under the system of the world nobles.
And so thematically this darkest of chapters
fits more than perfectly into the arguably
darkest arc of the series so far. All this
stuff with nobles, people being bought and
sold and walked around with collars, people
being sold like items in an auction house,
Hachi and Camie having to hide themselves
due to long-standing racism that's still
heavily ingrained in the people of the world.
And that is only the first part of the arc.
It leaves a quite disturbing and uncomfortable
feel on us readers, as we were mostly used to a
more adventure-based story-line with smaller
villains in between. Yet here the entire
political system of the world is revealed to be
twisted and broken, designed for the pleasure of
a selected few and exploiting the rest. Kid, who
I think got a wonderful introduction in this arc,
has a fantastic and incredibly
underrated speech about all this. I think
this hits it on the head. As Kid states
correctly, many pirates like himself
have done horrendous things. However they are
not a unified group like the world government.
And it was the terror, injustice and poverty
of the current system that lead to the high
level of piracy in the first place, Luffy’s
backstory being a great example of this.
And so I would argue that Oda
tries to make clear in this chapter
that the world government is overall the
greater evil compared to the pirates,
which is also why true change has come by
the hands of pirates such as Roger and Luffy.
So let’s finally talk about that punch, that
I think we all immensely enjoyed seeing.
It’s especially nicely done in the anime where
the change from black to white, Luffy’s walk,
Charlos’ dropping face as well as the unique
sound design really bring the scene to life
and multiply its impact. Based on everything we
have discussed so far, I think it’s very easy
to see what makes Luffy’s moment of pure anger
so cathartic. Luffy is the only one who dares
to stand up to the true injustice and tyranny
of the world, who actually shows Charlos you
can’t just do whatever to people and that actions
actually should have consequences, something that
no admiral, no yonko and no one else has dared
to do. In that sense, when Luffy punches Charlos
and bursts the bubble that is supposed to keep him
from breathing the same air as the common people,
Luffy also bursts his metaphoric bubble of
divine and unlimited power. Once again the D
as the natural enemy of the gods. Luffy committing
the ultimate sin and declaring war on the gods
themselves. Thus, what makes this scene so special
is that it is a moral and emotional island of
light in a see of darkness that is the sabaody
arc. Luffy giving us this moment of much needed
justice and courage that allows us to hope for
the world to truly change for the better with him.
Which is EXACTLY what so many other people
see in him. When the pirate captain bites
off his tongue earlier in the chapter to escape
slavery, Sanji in a great moment comments this.
It’s all about freedom. And his captan in
this scene is once again proving that he is
the freest of them all, free to actually do
the right thing and stand up to the world.
What ultimately makes this
moment even better for me however
is how in typical shakespearean fashion it is
the catalyst for even more tragedy to happen.
Luffy bravely punching Carlos leads to the
eviction of a Buster Call, during which Kizaru
and Shutenmaru completely overwhelm the crew as
well as the other supernova. In the end Luffy and
us readers had to witness how one by one each of
the straw hats disappears by the hands of Kuma,
resulting in maybe THE most shocking moment of
the entire story. The straw hat’s full defeat.
All, set up by this moment right here. This is
story telling and tragic writing at its peak.
And speaking of tragic writing at
its peak in the next video I want
to talk about one of the most tragic and
misunderstood moments after the time skip.
And so we’ll be looking at that in
the next video. Thanks guys. Peace.